yeah welcome to this blitz game playing
swap recently lost the game against him
I know it I remember all the pretty good
defense that he put up there that was a
d falling down now we have from this
line this modern line of them are
tangles variation or the neo Arkhangelsk
variation something like this I'm unsure
about the naming convention okay but um
anyway I don't don't know much just
developed normally talk like this trying
to play simple choice here yeah maybe he
can play t5s it's not particularly
threatening what I would I played him
but d5 i can probably take and then
slowly try to improve 95 Queenie to
something like that one idea of being
night you for to c5 if if allowed so
maybe still try that intending Nagi 5f
595 also yeah until now
still no g5 maybe protect III I'm
tending 95 maybe e-form try to get
something on f7
yeah I was intending deform now but he
can maybe take ed ed Bishop f5 yeah I'm
very annoying Bishop f5 don't really
have a good response to that I 92 I can
play 92 not ft 2 I can do that takes
takes Bishop f5 not ft two attacks the
bishop on 95 s probably I am probably in
batam care here yeah why not could have
taken first not shown
yeah after you tasty I cannot take with
the pawn that's a real shame
hmm
yeah I enough didn't I take on e6 first
and gathers feels like history repeating
are playing this guy and then here
defense accurately enter at the end
takes over
I really think that the exact play wide
was substantially better with the but
the weaknesses on the queenside but then
something wrong something went terribly
wrong okay but try to fight here still
the night on f5 always gives you some
hope it's not like my games it's not
like with Kasparov who said with a night
only five I'm unstoppable but at least
four for human player the night on f5 at
least provides some hope all right
and
thinking
night age six is a move I'm thinking
about night h 6 g takes rook f7 King a
jade and I've got no move I can take III
you can take III
you're threatening the rook it's not the
most M sub top layer 1 and it's hard to
get along without them securing the back
ring
maybe there's still some fight left in
this what is he actually doing now
hmm don't you don't really see a move a
good one I mean yeah this but it's not
particularly inspiring yeah for this is
corrupted one don't want dad probably
him slow should be a rather good chance
at the end game and attacking all of us
the airport
yeah it's equal material now I don't
tell me that's roughly two and I cannot
defend this look f7 well that seems to
be okay I can take and a 70 s check and
then we have to just get near skin
cannot take on b3 because of Queen at
five yeah his king is slightly slightly
weaker now get out of Queen deform
I don't really want to exchange with the
slightly I'm better King
check
oh come on rook f5 f5 champions winning
the Queen yeah all this one this was a
bit lucky yeah probably here this looks
like like excellent for white but this
is this just nonsense I need to look
look for a moment in and play a precise
move now just just just play player here
the problem why I'm saying that white
should be better here this is just very
weak the whole Queen side and the night
on c5 is excellent I just need to time
it correctly and my timing was simply
off if I take first here's something
like this it's just excellent i win a
tempo on the Queen and if it takes him
there's something like this for example
and now I don't know Queen c4i maybe I
can just just move away I just need to
establish this night iam and there's
also these ideas he's also got a weak
inside this is a very good position but
in the game I overlooked that simply
that this is saying I mean I just I just
didn't see it and this of course passes
the edge to to black and this is only
fishing here I'm not really working at
first I thought this was an idea it's
not working at all the ideas of course
this winning the rook and but he can
just take here's the first issue now you
don't even have a check and the easiest
of course is after this that's also
Queen III so this wasn't working and now
I'm just as mentioned
fishing group d 2 is good now yeah and
this is really computer gives Quincy
five check at g5 as the best move okay
but this is not easy to see and now i'm
i'm really a back in business and it's
even somewhat easier to play because of
the week king of here here can't a also
here can just play this yeah well it's a
time scramble not much else yeah
interesting thanks for watching